-It is great to see you, bud. Come on. You look great.
There's something I want to get into.
but I -- I just heard this,
that you took your youngest -- finally saw "Hamilton."
-Yes. I took my 4-year-old, Frankie, to "Hamilton."
-Little Frankie. -Little Frankie.
-He is the -- -Sunday matinee.
-He is the cutest kid on Earth. I mean, he really is.
-Yeah. -I love that kid so much.
But what did he think?
-It was -- it was very surreal. I had the both of them.
and he kind of alternated between the seat next to me
and -- and my lap.
"Ten Duel Commandments. Smash hit in our house.
'Cause it's kind of like the Number-Bots song in the show.
So they count in it, and he's very good at counting.
So he was like, "Number three."
He was holding his hand up like...
-He's -- He's this big. -"Number four!"
-He's so cute.
-And then the real surprise was "Dear Theodosia."
So, I didn't know this, but my wife sang him
"Dear Theodosia" to sleep, like, every night.
[ Audience awws ] And all he asks for before --
We do, like, the same routine every night.
it's like, we read three books and listen to the Regina Spektor
cover of "Dear Theodosia" from the "Mixtape."
So, he's only ever heard, like,
beautiful women singing this song.
And they start singing it on stage.
and he was sitting in my lap, and I hear this little voice go,
"What the heck?!"
That's from this? That's from this?"
-"That's from this?" -And then --
"That's from this?" -"That's from this?"
-And then he goes -- And then he fell asleep.
[ Laughter ] Because that's his bedtime song.
-That's his song.
-He was immediately triggered to sleep.
-And you're like, "You can't fall asleep during Daddy's..."
-"That's from this?"
-Yeah, you can't fall asleep during Daddy's play! Wake up!
-And he just went down. He was fine by intermission.
He enjoyed the second half. -Yeah. I love that kid, man.
-Yeah, he's the best. -Both of your kids are awesome.
This -- I'm almost freaking out to hold this.
Have you held it? have you held it?
-I have held it. I have beheld it.
-You have? You have your own song book.
-Yeah. This is my -- -Dude.
-Collective songs. -Wait. This is --
-It's everything from
"In the Heights" through "Encanto,"
and it doesn't -- You know, it's kind of like --
You do your show every night and you look back and you go,
"Oh, my God. I have done all of these shows."
To have a career's worth of songs
that are worthy of getting --
-Dude, just -- With the "Hal Leonard."
-The "Hal Leonard" really makes it real.
-Dude, I almost got emotional because I go --
-Because it connects you to,
like, when you were learning how to play music, right?
-You bought -- This was a giant thing.
-Yeah. I remember my books -- Like, my sheet-music books.
It was the complete Beatles. It was two parts.
-Yeah, I had that, too. -You had --
-The Beatles fake one.
-Oh, you had the Beatles fake book.
-I had the "Ultimate Broadway" fake book.
-Wow! -And it just had, like,
hundreds of show tunes.
And a fake book is just where they have the chords
over the melody.
-Like, the easiest way to do the song.
-Yeah, just read the chords and kind of fake it.
-But it's the best. -It's the best, man.
-I had that. Yeah, I had that. I think I had Billy Joel.
-Yeah. Billy Joel. If you had a piano, you had Billy Joel.
-Yeah, I couldn't do any of it. -Yeah, no.
-It was too advanced. I go, "Where's the fake one?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And what else did I --
I had the "Weird Al" song book, too.
Of course, I had the "Weird Al" song book.
-You had the "Weird Al" song book?
-Yeah, yeah, when he released the greatest hits,
it came out with the sheet music.
-No! -Hal Leonard.
-Dude. -Yeah.
-Oh, my God. Not saying anything, but Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I don't have it. That'd be amazing.
-Yeah.
-Are you excited for Al's movie? -Yes.
Yeah, Weird Al's movie coming out.
-It's coming out. The Weird Al Yan--
"Weird." It's called "Weird." -It's called "Weird."
-Weird Al Yankovic. I cannot wait for this thing.
-Yeah, Daniel Radcliffe plays Weird Al.
I'm, like, plugging someone --
I have nothing to do with this movie.
-No. Yeah, yeah.
-I just think you should all see it.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah. -Yeah.
But Weird -- Yeah, Daniel Radcliffe plays Weird Al.
-Don't you have a cameo in it or something?
-I might have a cameo in it. -Yeah, you might have something.
But when did you -- -I might have a cameo in it.
-Yeah. When did you -- When did you meet Al?
-So, this is, like, the worst story.
-Oh, no! -Because I'm --
I've -- Because of "Hamilton," I met everyone.
I met everyone on the Internet. I met them.
They all came to the show. -Everyone...has been there.
-Yeah, everyone you've ever googled came to "Hamilton."
But this was way -- Years pre-"Hamilton,"
he was looking to maybe write a musical,
and he was meeting with writers.
And so I took a meeting
at his house... -What?
-...in Hollywood, and I drove there myself in a rented car.
And it's like meeting Santa Claus
meeting Weird Al.
-Yes! it's Weird Al Yankovic.
-And I was so nervous that I, like --
I, like, self-destructed. Like, midway through it, I said,
"You know who you should work with? Bobby Lopez."
-Bobby Lopez. -Bobby Lopez, who wrote
"Frozen" and "Encanto" and "Book of Mormon."
I was like, "He's writing a show with the 'South Park' guys.
They're funny. You're funny. You should write with them..."
and, like, talked him out of working with me.
And then, like, got --
Some self-esteem thing happened to me.
it's never happened before!
And -- And I got in my car, and I was like
the guy in "Boogie Nights."
I was like, "You're an idiot. You're an idiot.
Why did you do that?! Why did you do that?!"
-Oh, my God. [ Sad tuba plays ]
-And -- Yeah.
[ Imitates "Price is Right" loser horn ]
-Because we've talked about how much we idolized Weird Al.
I mean, he's one of my -- -But the first time,
I really pooped the bed.
It's amazing he's friends with me.
Because the first time I was like, "H-H-Hi."
-But then you -- you ended up working together
when he did the "Hamilton"... -Yes, yes. Now we're...
-Did you write song parodies when you were a kid?
-I did. -Like, "Weird Al" versions?
-I dreamed -- My ambition was not as high
as writing musicals when I was a kid.
My dream was maybe Weird Al might retire
and I could be the next one. -Yes!
-That was, like, my childhood dream.
-Yeah. -And --
-Of course. -I got --
I got straight C's in mathematics in high school,
like, really C's and D's in math
except for one year where --
God bless Miss Yallos, who was my teacher.
She allowed you to do creative projects to bring up your grade.
And I rewrote Billy Joel's "For the Longest Time"
to "Before the Law of Sines."
-And I explained the sine law --
sine/cosine law with the lyrics, the rewritten lyrics.
♪ For the law of sines ♪
♪ If you take the thing of angle B ♪
I don't remember. Again, I got C's in math.
-I think -- I think I wrote -- My first one I wrote was --
Because I was trying to be Weird Al.
But I think I wrote, "I wish I Were King Kong Bundy."
You know "Manic Monday"?
-Oh, yeah. -And I was like --
♪ I wish I was King Kong Bundy ♪
-♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
-♪ I wrestle on Sunday ♪
That's great! -Something like that.
'Cause I was into wrestling, and I was like --
Yeah, King Kong Bundy, man. Yeah. Never went anywhere.
-And now we're here.
-Yeah, exactly. That's so wild, buddy.
I know you're going -- You're always doing something cool.
But you're off to Vegas...
-Yes. -...at the Venetian.
Can you explain what you're doing there?
-So, Freestyle Love Supreme, who has performed on the show.
-My fave.
-We are doing, like, a sitdown in Vegas.
We're like Celine Dion.
We're going to Vegas. We're sitting down.
-You have a residency there?
-Yeah, we have a residency at the --
at the Venetian Resort, Las Vegas.
And we start performances November 10th.
But I'm jumping in the show the 16th and 17th of November.
And it's -- -It's the most fun show.
If you've not seen it, it is --
-Well, it's a completely improvised show.
Like, we -- the show is based entirely
on the audience's suggestions.
And one of the games we play is "Day in the Life,"
where we bring someone up, we ask them about their day.
Like, if you were in Vegas, you had an interesting day.
Something went -- It just feels like --
-Vegas is going to be insane. -Vegas is going to be insane.
-You're like, "what did you do?"
"Oh, get ready for what we did today."
It's like, "Oh, my gosh. You did that?"
I don't even know if you can talk about what you did today."
-Yeah, so I'm very excited for the chaotic energy.
-Oh. Congrats on that. -Yeah.
-And then "Encanto," this giant thing at the Hollywood Bowl.
-Yeah. -This is wild.
-So, this is the voice -- the actual voice cast of "Encanto."
Steph Beatriz. Everyone you love.
And it's the first time performing live
in front of an audience.
And they're singing all the songs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you going to be there? -I'm going to be there.
I'm going to introduce everyone and -- and then enjoy the show.
-I should say also if you can't make it to the Hollywood Bowl,
Disney Plus is going to air it on December --
-Yeah, it's going to be on Disney Plus after Christmas.
-December 28th. -Yeah.
-Yeah. Congrats, by the way, on "Encanto" winning
Best Animated Film at the Oscars.
-Yeah, how about that? -Not too shabby, dude.
-It's pretty crazy. -Not too shabby.
-Not too shabby. -Yeah.
Speaking of "Encanto," we're going to do something fun.
Always something fun,
always something musical when you come on.
I want to know if you want to continue that tradition.
-Yeah. -Okay, good.
More with Lin-Manuel Miranda when we come back everybody.
Stick around. Come back.